depuis que nous construisons l'univers
cinématographique Marvel, nous avons
construit cette idée des pierres Infinity et
ce qui est amusant avec les pierres Infinity dans
les bandes dessinées, c'était les gemmes de l'infini telles
qu'elles étaient connues au départ, c'est
comme cet énorme ensemble incroyablement puissant
de MacGuffins faute d'un meilleur mot,
ils existaient en quelque sorte à ce
niveau cosmique, cela représentait le point culminant
de tout l'univers Marvel, nous avons eu
l'idée il y a des années si nous pouvions faire du
Infinity Gauntlet la grande chose
qui domine toute la
cinématique Marvel  Univers qu'il a en quelque sorte culminé
dans un film de guerre à l'infini Thanos a
toujours été une sorte de grand marionnettiste
parce qu'il est vraiment un dieu encore plus
que Thor, il est comme un être suprême du
mal, donc l'idée qu'il était le principal
moteur derrière tout cela  semblait juste
naturel une fois qu'il a ce qui est rempli et
qu'il a toutes les pierres alors tout est
possible
vous